Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với có học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube và Excel bài số
19 in ấn trong Excel trước khi đi vào
bài tập số 19 mình không giải cách câu
hỏi của bài số 18 hôm trước nhé các bạn
xem mở cái câu hỏi của bà 18 lên ok cái
câu hỏi là diện Đây là cái vùng dữ liệu
mình sẽ làm sao để mình làm được cái
biểu đồ tương tác như cái phần này đúng
ạ Đấy thì các bạn sẽ vào cái xui dữ liệu
của các bạn này mình sẽ tạm cái sim mới
nha các bạn sẽ thích và cái dấu cộng này
đây là ví dụ vì sửa tên sheet thì có
xích đu các bạn sửa là diện lời giải là
thế nhá đấy thì cái cách đơn giản là gì
cả các bạn xem copy này các bạn nhấn
chuột phải các bạn copy xong copy lại
các bạn vào cái ship lời giải ví dụ phân
tích và đang cho enter đi đấy để mình
lấy cái dữ liệu thôi các bạn sẽ xóa cái
này đi nhá mình sẽ dùng công thức này sẽ
thích lúc này ở đây là gì mình sẽ là
chọn chọn quý cho hạ thế nhá Ừ
đã diễn ra một cái danh sách chọn xuống
là cái ôn này đi bây giờ bị rửa mình tô
màu này thì cô này mình sẽ tô màu à
phụ tùng mô đen này trẻ không nhìn nó
đẹp hơn thôi lại Bây giờ mình sẽ chọn
Quý nhé quý thì mình sẽ cho nên màu lại
bây giờ chắc chọn quý thì mình sẽ tạo
cái danh sách xổ số này có bạn xuất kích
vào cái ô thể oc2 này các bạn sẽ vào thẻ
data các bạn sẽ chọn gì data-validation
đấy thì trong cái thẻ setting nhá một
Alo các bạn sẽ chọn cho mình led vào cái
phần short nhá chọn sẽ gõ cho mình là
diện các bạn sẽ gõ cho mình đầu tiên là
ôn này Đấy phẩm tiếp theo là có bạn sẽ
có bốn cái Quý đúng không và các bạn chú
ý nhé Cái quý nó phải giống hai cái tiêu
đề này Tại vì Lát nữa mình sẽ áp dụng
các công thức cho nên ở đây mình sẽ gõ
đúng cái tên này Đây là quý một đúng
không Mình sẽ làm đây để cho con hiểu
lại mình sẽ gõ đúng từ quý 1 đến cái
bống nhá Đấy sau cái dấu phẩy này gọi sẽ
ghi là Thúy một này quý một này phải ạ
quý quý hai phẩy quý 3,1
em nói như vậy là gì ạ ôn này và 4 cách
quý này và tên nó phải giống hệt cái
phần tiêu đề đây nhá các bạn sẽ bấm ok
đấy thì như vậy con thấy chưa nó là tạo
một cái danh sách xổ xuống rồi Tiếp theo
mình sẽ nhập công thức nhé đấy Ở đây
mình sẽ bằng để các bạn sẽ bằng ít này
các bạn ứng tác này ít diện nếu như mà
có sử dụng cái hàng o o o của mở ngoặc
đơn ra nếu như mà diện cái oc2 này các
bạn sẽ nhấn F4 nhá thì tại sao lại F4
Tại vì cái oc2 này là cái ô mình cần nó
cố định Khi mình áp dụng với công thức
này xuống dưới hoặc là sang bên phải mà
băng hiện bằng mở ngoặc kép ra bằng ôn ạ
sẽ đóng ngoặc kép lại hoặc là rẽ phải
hoặc là vẫn là cái oc2 này các bạn cũng
phải ấn F4 nữa đấy mặc bằng với ạ bằng
cái tiêu đề là quý một này Đấy tức là
bằng cái oc4 đúng không các bạn sẽ nhấn
4 cho mình một hai lần thì tại sao lại
ép 42 lần lại
Ừ thì mình sẽ áp dụng công thức này sang
bên phải này thì khi mà các bạn áp dụng
sang bên phải tức là cái cổ thay đổi
đúng không Thế lúc này xe nó sẽ thay đổi
tương ứng là df Đấy tức là nó sẽ dịch
chuyển là các quý tương ứng đúng không
Con số 4 này là diện khi các bạn áp dụng
công thức này xuống dưới thì nó sẽ vẫn
lấy cái phần tiêu đề ở đây đấy Bạn thấy
không tín nghĩa là như vậy nhé Đấy Bây
giờ cậu sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lại để xong
cái Hà Nho này như vậy là cái biểu thức
lôgic của mình là diện nếu như mà cái ô
chọn quý ở đây nó bằng ôn hoặc nó bằng
phím ổn định thì mình sẽ lấy giá trị là
gì mình sẽ lấy ra chị phải mình sẽ xanh
đấy ship dữ liệu đây là xin một lúc nào
cũng sẽ lấy tương ứng là quý 1 của các
bạn gái sau một này đấy còn chúng ta khi
gọi tích vào cái ô ký một ở đây chỗ nào
oc3 của ca sĩ một đây này thì đừng ở nhé
40 cả nha các bạn cứ để như thế này cho
mình đấy Tại vì sao tại vì phim đã áp
dụng công thức xuống dưới sang phải thì
nó sẽ dịch cái oc3 này tương ứng xuống
dưới hoặc là sang bên phải đấy Bây giờ
gọi sẽ phải nhá Nếu như mà Rịa ngược lại
thì có rất ít
ở đó hoặc các phương thức là các bạn trả
về cái biểu thức trắng để gọi xem đóng
ngoặc đơn cho enter đấy thì như vậy Ở
đây mình chưa chọn cái gì cả đúng không
Thì nó sẽ kết quả trắng có thích vào đây
Các bạn chọn ô này Đấy con thấy chưa nó
sẽ ra 79 hoặc các bạn chọn quý 1 thì nó
cũng ra về chín Còn nếu như bạn chọn quý
hay đấy thì nó sẽ không ra gì cả chọn
xóa đi lại nó sẽ không ra gì cả đúng
không ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ thích lại vào
cái ô vì Ôsin Nam là ô công thức uống họ
sẽ kéo sang thì áo xanh phải là để các
bạn lại kéo xuống dưới đây Thì như vậy
mình đã có công thức cho toàn bộ các quý
và các bạn này nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ cho
các bạn này chọn cho ôn này Đấy con thấy
chưa Đấy rất là hay hoặc là quý một này
thì chỉ có cái một cột quý một này nó có
giá trị 0 và là thứ hai này Đấy chỉ có
quý 2 này có giá trị không để rất là hai
ạ thì như vậy cái dữ liệu của mình là
diện nó đã được tự động bằng các khách
hàng rồi đúng không ạ bây giờ ví dụ mình
chọn ôn đi bây giờ mình sẽ vừa rồi nhé
mình sẽ Bôi đen toàn một cái vùng dữ
liệu này đấy các bạn vào cái thẻ Insert
thì các bạn chọn cái biểu đồ thì ở đây
theo cái yêu cầu thì phải chọn các biểu
đồ này tức là nó sẽ + tổng cái túi lên
thì nó sẽ đẹp hơn đúng không ạ bây giờ
ví dụ minh tinh đây mình chọn là quý một
đúng không ạ Đấy thì nó nhảy được quý mô
rồi nhưng mà nó còn thiếu cái gì Các bạn
xa người yêu cầu này nó còn thiếu cái
phần doanh thu đây này còn thấy khi mà
các bạn sợ ông á thì nó sẽ là doanh thu
cả năm còn nếu như bạn thật phí một thì
nó sẽ là điện doanh thu quý 1 đấy nếu
như là quý 3 thẳng thế nhá thì nó sẽ đạp
điện doanh thu quý 3 như vậy là mình
phải sửa cái tiêu đề ngoài ra gì mình sẽ
thêm cái phần giá trị ở đây lại lấy giá
trị ở Cái dưới này không thấy là như vậy
mình phải bổ sung thêm hai cái phần nữa
nhá bây giờ mình sẽ vào với xin lời giải
này nói cái phần trà Thay tổ Như vậy cái
phần trả thay cho mình phải sử dụng công
thức được mình sẽ tạo một cái ô phụ ở
đây ví dụ như là cái ô em một để cọ xát
tích vậy em một nhé đấy các bạn thích
lạnh và các em muốn đi con bằng này các
bạn sẽ mở một phép lạ bạn sẽ ghi là
doanh thu
cha mẹ cậu sẽ cách là bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc
kép lại sau đó gọi và mới dễ và ít bạn
mở ngoặc ra nếu như bà Rịa cái ô C2 này
bằng bằng màu Kép bằng Ôn các bạn đóng
ngoặc kép vậy bạn sẽ phải gọi sẽ trả về
cái gì Các bạn sẽ trả về cái chuỗi là
cao có ghi là cả năm để lát mình giải
thích các bạn nha con đóng và các bạn
phẩy Còn nếu ngược lại thì các lấy giá
trị luôn là cái oc2 này đấy các bạn xem
đóng ngoặc đơn lại để xong Hà mít bây
giờ gặp em chơi đi thì như vậy là diện
cái E1 này Nếu như các bạn chọn phí một
định thì nó sẽ nào doanh thu quý 1 cậu
thích vào đây đến như là quý 2 thì nó sẽ
xảy ra là kênh Du Ký 2 đúng không Nếu
trợ ngôn thì nó sẽ là doanh thu cả năm
đấy Bây giờ có xét tích vào cái ô chạc
thay đổi lại họ sẽ lên cái tang Phong L3
là có bằng cát bằng với cái E1 này là
cái ô mà chứa cái tiêu đề ngắn gọn enter
bạn thấy chưa doanh thu cả năm này các
bạn chọn quý một này thì nó sẽ gọi điện
cho
Ừ để đó là hai ạ Bây giờ gọi sẽ tích và
Cái ô thì cho em một này các bạn đổi màu
cho nó nhá đổi màu cho nó là màu trắng
đi để các bạn nhìn ẩn đi bạn thấy chưa
nhỉ các bạn không nhìn thấy gì cả nhìn
nó đẹp hơn đúng không đấy anh vô cả năm
Bây giờ mình sẽ thêm cái phần gì ạ thêm
cái phần tổng doanh thu vào xuống dưới
này nhá Đây thì bạn có thể tạo thêm một
cái cột ở đây bên này là tổng này cả thế
nhá các bằng này với cả Tên này Đấy đoạn
và với diện và với cái hành trang mười
là tiện tra mười là để lấy cái ký tự
enter Tức là mình sẽ tạo hai cái hiện
mình sẽ tạo hai cái hành trên một ô đúng
không Tức là diện cho biểu diễn nên là
hai cái hàng Thuận và với dượng và với
cả gì mở ngoặc kép hoặc đơn ra các diện
chọn đó mà kẹp lại gọn và với hàm xăng
mở ngoặc đơn ra Quan Sông xăm của 4 quý
này các bạn đó đơn lại sau đó bạn và bây
giờ ta mở ngoặc kép ra đóng ngoặc đơn ạ
Nó khép lại cái gặp enter a
thí sinh ở đây nha phải tiếng lúc này
Bây giờ gọi Nháy chuột phải vào cái biểu
đồ này các bạn chọn select data để các
thích bảo vệ gallas này bên phải nhá Đấy
cái này nó đang là diện nó đang là cái
phần tên ở bên này Bây giờ bạn sẽ xóa đi
các bạn sẽ gán lại bằng cái tên mình tạo
mới đây để dọn bấm ok với cả Ok bạn thấy
chưa Như vậy doanh thu tổng đây rồi lại
rất là hay luôn đây quý 3 đã thứ nhất
đây tổng của quý 3 thôn tổng ôn lại rất
là hai ạ Như vậy mình đã xong cái câu
trả lời cho bài số 18 nhé các bạn sân
bóng lại Ok mình sẽ vào bài 19 Hôm nay
là in ấn trong Excel bạn Facebook lên
các bạn xem ở cái phần Yến trong Excel
lên hôm nay mình sẽ hướng dẫn cho các
bạn toàn bộ 18 cái thủ thuật liên quan
đến phần in ấn nhá 28 này rất là hay đấy
có thủy mình sẽ để cái link tải file
thực hành trong phần mô tả phía dưới
video tốt nhất là các bạn tải
các bạn vừa theo dõi và thực hành của
mình nhá Nếu những bạn nào mà không biết
cách tải về thì các bạn có thể theo dõi
Cái bài đầu tiên thì trong bài đấy mình
đã hướng dẫn các bạn là cái cách chi
tiết để các bạn tải về nhá OK cái thủ
thuật đầu tiên là mình sáng tạo cái nút
print preview đấy nếu như mà các bạn hay
phải ghim thì gọi sẽ tạo một cái nút ở
bên trên đây này Đấy giống như kiểu cái
bút xếp này các bạn chỉ cần kích vào đây
là được đấy hoặc nút undo hoặc là
legendee lại chỗ nào nó sẽ tạo một cái
nút nhanh ở đây để bạn chọn này đấy thì
các bạn sẽ thích vào cái phần tam giác
Nhỏ đây này nó gọi là casta Quick access
toolbar này Đấy và các bạn thích chọn
cái print preview thôi đấy thì ngay lập
tức nó sẽ có một cái biểu tượng là print
preview Ở đây bây giờ cậu thích làm đấy
thì như vậy là cái preview đã hiện ra
lại rất là nhanh chóng ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ
bấm Bách lại nhá hoặc các bạn sẽ bầu bí
kíp quay lại đi đấy hoặc là cái phím tắt
là có ấn can Trương pê cũng được thì nó
cũng ra là cái print preview lại Bây giờ
mình sẽ vẫn biết kiếp nhé đấy thì nếu
như
khi sử dụng cái in Thế bạn có thể tạo
các biểu tượng là print preview của trên
này nhá Ok xanh cái thủ thuật thứ hai là
mình chọn máy in nhá để họ phân tích vào
đây Thì như vậy cái phần chọn máy in cái
phần thiện chính là cái printer ở đây
này các bạn sẽ thích vào đây thì nó sẽ
liệt kê cho các bạn toàn bộ các hệ máy
in mà các bạn đang có đấy Thế còn chuối
nhá ở đây mình không có cái máy in thì
nó sẽ không hiện thôi Còn nếu như các
bạn chọn in ra giấy tức là các bạn đang
có kết nối đến máy in và các bạn chọn
cái máy in trong cái phần mạng LAN của
các bạn thì bạn sẽ thích nào nhá thì ở
đây do mình không có ví dụ mình chọn cái
máy in pdf đi Tức là diện nó sẽ lưu cái
file này ra cái file pdf đấy bây giờ ví
dụ mình bấm linh á thì nếu như mà các
bạn in ra giấy thì các bạn sẽ thấy in ra
giấy luôn nhưng mà do mình in pdf Tức là
mình sẽ lưu cái file này dưới gặp em ấy
thì nó sẽ hiện của cái cửa sổ để các bạn
đặt tên cái file PDF của mình mỗi in
đúng không Để anh Ví dụ mình đặt cái
file flash là tên mặc định đi Là bài 19
in ấn đây này Nó sẽ lưu vào viện
documents lại ví dụ như
anh cảm thấy nhé còn thích là desktop
Các bạn bấm xếp Vậy thì bây giờ có bạn
sẽ vào destop đấy nó xem ở luôn cho các
bạn ạ Bạn thấy đấy Đây là một cách để
bạn có thể lưu file thế dưới dạng PDF
nhanh chóng nhá bằng cách các bạn
internet cũng được thủ thuật thứ ba là
rẻ mình có thể in được 1 sheet 1 file
hoặc là một vùng được chọn đúng không
Thì chả sửa đây mình có ba suýt nhé Mình
muốn in cả file hoặc đi một ít hoặc một
vùng thì mình làm như thế nào thì bạn
vẫn là thích vào cái biểu tượng là print
preview ở đây hoặc các bạn bấm can CP
cũng được nhắc ví dụ cá trên p đi Đấy
thêm con Thúy là cái vùng này cái vùng
Dream factsheet Đây là cái mặc định á
Tức là mẹ nó sẽ in cái ship mà mình đang
thao tác bố rằng các bạn sẽ thích vào
đây thì nó sẽ có thêm các tùy chọn khác
ví dụ là diện nếu như bạn chọn cái này
Rin anti Facebook như thế nào nó sẽ in
toàn bộ cả cái file của bạn thì lúc này
nó sẽ có tất cả là việc 36 trang Các bạn
nhìn xuống dưới này 36 trang đấy còn
thấy rất là nhiều trang luôn Hoặc là gì
Các bạn sẽ chọn được cái pin
Ừ Thế lúc nãy mình chưa chọn cái xe
Lexus được gì cả đúng không Thì nó lại
in cái tiêu đề đây bây giờ ví dụ các bạn
biết kiếp đi Đấy bây giờ ví dụ mình muốn
in cái vùng dữ liệu mà mình Bôi đen như
thế này thôi nhá hoặc là diện đây cái
tiêu đề Ví dụ mình in 10 cái thủ thuật
này thôi và cái phần tiêu đề đấy mình
Bôi đen nhá sau đó bạn bấm các TP đi đấy
ở cái phần setting này các bạn chọn à
prince Jackson con thấy chưa thì nó chỉ
in cái phần mà mình modem thôi đấy là
cái cách để mình có thể in một vùng cả
một sheet hoặc là diện toàn bộ file bây
giờ mình sẽ chọn mặc định là toàn bộ
ship thì ship này nó cũng chỉ có một
trang không Lúc này là diện Đây là 18
thuộc thuật đây cảm thấy rất là hai
tranh thủ thuật thứ tư là mình sẽ in một
số trang nhất định nhá lại các bạn sẽ
nhấn tăng phê này thì bạn chú ý nhất
trong cái phần P ở đây này Nó sẽ có là
diện từ trang nào đến trang nào thì mặc
định là diện nó sẽ tin toàn bộ tất cả
các trang bây giờ ví dụ mình chọn cả cái
file này đi em thoại Facebook nhá thì
tất cả
Ừ cái file này nó sẽ có tất cả là 36
trang đúng không Đây này các bạn có thể
in Ví dụ mình trang in thời trang 1 đến
diện đến trang 10 được hạn thế nhá Đấy
để chọn sẽ nhập 1 đến 10 vào đây Còn nếu
như các bạn mũi một cái trang cụ thể ví
dụ trang bảy cả thế nhá thì các bạn sẽ
bị từ 7 đến đến 7 thôi đấy thì nó sẽ in
1 cái trang cụ thể cho các bạn ấy sau đó
các bạn ấn free là được Đấy Bây giờ mình
sẽ ít kiếp đi thủ thuật từ năm rồi Liệu
mình sẽ chọn cái chiều ngang hoặc dọc
khi in Đúng không các bạn vẫn là chọn
cái bên preview này Đấy thử ở đây này
cái phần gì ạ Cái phần BOT xây orenthal
đây này thì thông thường mặc định là nó
sẽ in theo cái khổ giấy chiều rộng thì
còn có thể chọn đấy in the khổ hình
nhanh ấy còn thấy thấy Hoặc là các bạn
chọn lại là rọc thì tùy các bạn nhé Nếu
như mà dữ liệu của bạn được bố trí theo
chiều ngang thì các bạn Lênin cái chiều
ngang để các tiết kiệm giấy và nó sẽ đẹp
hơn đấy ok xanh cái tục thứ sáu là điện
cách hiển thị cái lề trang in là sâu
Marin đúng ạ Các bạn ấn các chân pedi
vậy thì ngay lập tức các bạn sẽ nhìn
sang cái góc dưới ở bên phải đây này Đấy
cả sẽ tích và cái xấu mưa zin này thì nó
sẽ hiện các cái điểm chấm ở đây là cái
mưa phim và con có thể kéo nhá Đấy ví dụ
mình kéo sang pi đây là mình sẽ cắn nè
không thích đây đó tùy các bạn nhá vì
cái dữ liệu của mình ít thì nó không có
bạn không nhìn thấy tác dụng tôi dữ liệu
nhiều gọn sẽ thấy lại ví dụ các bạn xanh
đấy trang thứ hai đi lại Bây giờ các bạn
có thể kéo cái này lên à để bạn thấy
rằng nó sẽ dịch lên thì đôi khi các bạn
cần phải làm như thế này để nó sẽ tiết
kiệm với trang in của các bạn nhá đấy
thì tùy vào mục đích giải gọn ý thiếp đi
học các bạn bác chạy tiếp theo là liệu
mình sẽ thay đổi kích thước từ in về cm
thì thông thường trong cái phần quản lý
văn bản Người ta quy định là gì cái kích
thước căn trái là bao nhiêu cần phải là
bao nhiêu trên là bao nhiêu dưới bao
nhiêu với cái đơn vị là Cm nhưng mà mặc
định của mình nó là là inch
cho ví dụ các bạn ứng HP đi đấy bạn nhìn
cái phần điện đây là cách cổ dưới đây
này Nó đơn vị lại ngày 8.5 inchs 14 inch
hoặc là dạng cái card memory cảm thấy
đơn vị của nó đều là in này cái dấu nháy
kép ở trên này con thấy chưa Toàn nào rẻ
toàn là in hết bây giờ mình sẽ đổi về cm
và cách nào nhé Mình vẫn biết thiếp đi
thì con sẽ vào thẻ file này sau đó các
bạn vào option nhá lại thì ở đây của
mình Accent 2019 auction nó lạnh nằm ở
cái mục ngon này các bạn thích nó option
đấy sau đó gọn vào cái thẻ Advance nhá
Bây giờ gọi kéo xuống nhá lại còn đang
xuống này thì trong các nhóm pixplay nhá
Ở cái dung email này các bạn thấy nó đi
for unit này còn thích nữa đây đấy thì
bạn sẽ chọn là cái xentimét cho mình đấy
và các bạn xem bấm ok Bây giờ các bạn sẽ
rẻ các bạn review đi đấy Bạn thấy chứ
chứ Vậy toàn bộ Cái gì cả các bạn thấy
chứ đơn vị Nó rất chuyển được cm rồi đấy
hoặc là cái cá tầm
ở đó là Cm rồi và các bạn dễ dàng các
bạn sẽ tùy chỉnh cho nó nhá Đấy Ok các
bạn bằng cách lại đi sang thủ thuật thứ
tám là diện Thay đổi lề trang in Bạn có
thể vào cái Flash Player này đấy các bạn
chọn cái mưa zin và các bạn chọn cát
tường nhá các tướng lĩnh đấy còn có thể
thay đổi ở trên này thì tùy vào cái văn
bản của bạn đây còn thấy cho cái thẻ
Morgan này còn có thể tăng dạng thì tùy
các bạn nhé Đây là đơn vị là xentimét
rồi đấy Đấy sau khi căn giảm xong thì
các bạn bấm ok là được nhá tiếp theo là
diện tự căn chỉnh vào một trang in bây
giờ mình sang cái phần kế hoạch kinh
doanh đấy đi bây giờ các bạn bấm ktp gọi
cho thế này các bạn ấn các chân phê thế
bạn thấy chưa Đây lợn các bạn đang chọn
gỗ phục Ví dụ mình chọn nào bôxit đây
thì cái này nó đang là tất cả đó là mở 4
trang đúng không Bây giờ làm sao để cái
dữ liệu này mình sẽ ko về một trang
không thì mình là như thế nào đấy thì
rất là đơn giản thì các bạn sẽ vào cái
phần điện các bạn tích vào đây này Nó
đang làm
ông Kerry nha còn thích xuống dưới đây
này các bạn sẽ chọn cái gì gọi nói chọn
này Fix it on one piece tức là diện nó
sẽ co lại toàn bộ dữ liệu và một cái
trang in rồi còn thích vào đây đấy thì
như vậy Lúc đấy đang là 4 trang nó sẽ ko
vào một trang in 1 của một nơi này cảm
thấy không rất là đẹp thì cái này cũng
tùy thôi nhá thì nếu như dữ liệu của bạn
rất là dài rất là nhiều thì các bạn ko
vào một trang in thì nó rất là bé thì
với một số trường hợp thì ko vào một
trang in rất là đẹp nhưng mà một số
trường hợp thì nó sẽ không phù hợp với
cả cái dữ liệu và các bạn nhá thì ok sau
đó bạn bấm vào đi là được nhé mình sẽ
bắt lại sang thủ thuật thứ 10 là in giữa
trang giấy nhé các bạn sẽ ấn kahchan phê
này Đấy sau đó các bạn chọn cái quét tất
rồi đấy các bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ emoji đợi
thì ăn chuối nhá Nếu như có thích chọn
hai cái mục này thì có nhìn đây này thì
nó diện nó sẽ cắn giữq của bên trái và
bên phải Và nó sẽ căn giữa cả trên cả
dưới bây giờ lớn như
số máy này đi Tức là thiệt đó chỉ căn
giữa trái và phải thôi còn nhìn cái hình
mẫu này còn nếu như các bạn bỏ chọn ở
đây đi thì nó sẽ về mặc định là nó sẽ
cắn ở bên trái này bây giờ ví dụ mình
chọn cái này đi Tôi bảo nó sẽ tăng giữa
trái và phải nha cọ sẽ bấm ok đấy Bạn
thấy chưa thì nó sẽ ko lên trên và nó sẽ
ăn giữa của bên trái và bên phải luôn
lại rất là đẹp thì tùy các bạn nhé Sau
đó các bạn bấm print thôi xanh thủ thuật
thứ 11 là tao hết đơ và phút tờ nhá Bây
giờ các bạn ấn con phê đi đấy ví dụ ở
đây mình chọn là dễ mình chọn anti Quốc
bút này đi Thế là từ trang 1 đến trang
31 này Bây giờ có bạn sẽ vào cái gì Các
bạn rất thích chọn cái phết xếp tất các
bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ hết Đợi em router Ví
dụ mình chọn cái cát tầm hơn đời trước
đi thì bọn chúng á nó sẽ khó ba cái vùng
để mình Đạt hết đơ Ví dụ mình đã biết
trái này đã được giữ lại Họ đã biết phải
làm ví dụ nhà để bên trái đi bị cháy ví
dụ mình đặt tên là gái xe này nhá này ra
sẽ bấm ok Bây giờ bạn rất tích
ở tầm phức tạp ví dụ diện cái foot ở đây
mình chọn ở bên phải đi nhá và bạn sẽ
chọn cái số Trang thông thường mình chọn
thời trang mà các bạn thích đây là
Insert tết năm bờ để bây giờ gọi thêm 4
Ok bạn sẽ bấm ok thì bạn thấy chứ Đây là
cái hết đời là vào đây là cái phút tơ là
cái số trang thì cái số trang nằm bên
phải Và cái hết đơ nó sẽ làm bên trái ở
trên đó các bạn bốn vách lại nhé Sao cái
thử thuộc thứ hai lần diệu biết Break
preview bây giờ mình sẽ sang cái chết là
kế hoạch kinh doanh nhá chẳng hạn là
diện Đây là cái vùng dữ liệu còn đây là
cái biểu đồ bây giờ mình muốn gì mình
muốn cái biểu đồ này Nó ở cái trang thứ
hai chẳng in thứ 2 tức là dễ biểu đồ ở
một cái Trang và dễ cái dữ liệu ở một
trang thì mình là như thế nào các bạn và
preview đi các bạn sẽ bỏ cái gì Cái này
mình sẽ bỏ phí đi mình sẽ bỏ lâu scaring
bây giờ bạn sẽ tích và đây là các bạn
chọn là cái trên này là prinect tiếp này
đấy thì lúc đấy mình đang để là Fix it
on page này có thích vào đây mình sẽ
chọn là lâu
từ trước bây giờ các bạn cách lại nhé
đấy các bạn lại vào lại cái gì À cái Tết
Break preview này Đấy bây giờ qua sẽ thế
này nó tất cả là đang ở bốn trang của
các Nhìn cái sọc màu xanh đây này Đấy là
cái cái Chanh đây này Đấy bây giờ có chỉ
cần kéo cái sọc lên đây là đây là sau cổ
trang một cận kéo lên đây lại tức là
diện cái trang một nó chỉ đến với vùng
này tốt ở đây cái phần đồ thị nó đang ở
trang 2 này phải con theo kết 1 này kết
4 này phía ta bây giờ cậu có thể kéo dọc
theo đây Thì như vậy là gì ạ Cái p1 sẽ
là cái vùng dữ liệu và Tết hay là cái
phần đồ thị này bạn rất là hay thôi Bây
giờ có ấn Santafe để gói tin nhá Đấy còn
thấy cho Đây là cái cái ship một là cái
dữ liệu này các bạn hack phải thì xin
hay là cái biểu đồ hãy còn thấy ông rất
là hay luôn tranh thủ thuật chủ đề 3 lại
bỏ Life Black bây giờ ví dụ các bạn ấn
kgp nhé và dù các bạn nên không ghi Các
bạn bấm Viết tiếp đi
các bạn sẽ thấy cái phần live Black này
cái phần đường chấm chấm Nhỏ thế này đấy
thì các bạn có thể đóng vai hoặc các bạn
mở file lên thì nó lại luôn luôn hiện
cái này Đấy cận thì nhiều bạn sẽ thấy
cái phần like page này rất là khó chịu
được gạch chấm chấm đây ạ Bây giờ để bỏ
cái like Black này thì gọi là như thế
nào nhá lại còn sẽ báo với thể pha các
bạn sẽ vào option này thì của mình
Accent 2019 oslo nằm trong cái phần more
thì của các bạn thì thông thường góp thì
nó sẽ nằm ở dưới này luôn nhá mình sẽ
vào option lại và gọn sẽ vào để các bạn
sẽ vào cái thẻ SV này gọn anh xuống dưới
bạn xuống cái phần nhờ diện Display of
sonoris này các bạn bỏ cái phần sâu hết
Blackberry bạn sẽ bấm ok đấy Bạn thấy
chứ còn không thấy like Ajax ở đây nữa
thì nhiều bạn không biết cách này đâu
Cái này cũng khá là hay đấy sang thủ
thuật thứ 14 Lại in cái gslide bây giờ
có ấn các TP này đây thì khi các bạn ấn
cân p thì cái vùng dữ liệu của bạn này
các bạn thấy đâu
anh không thấy guerrilla Các bạn bấm vào
kết đi cái rồi dri chính là cái này Đây
này bây giờ bạn sẽ và có thể viên nhá
cái bây giờ các bạn bỏ chọn rồi regis
đây căn đấy chứ Đấy gọn tích chọn đây
lại tức là nó sẽ ăn cá Cái ô này lại bây
giờ mình muốn cái email này thì gọi là
như thế nào Thế bạn chỉ cần vào với
Faith leo này thì bạn nhìn cái phần dưới
lại đây nha các bạn sẽ tích và các thành
viên rồi đấy Đấy bây giờ các bạn ấn can
trên pc vậy chứ Đấy bạn thấy thì như vậy
cái vùng dữ liệu nó sẽ in thêm cả cái
rất là rất là cái dri của cái vùng dữ
liệu Thôi nhá Còn cái clip la ở bên
ngoài vùng dữ liệu thì nó sẽ không tin
nữa giả còn thấy rất là hai ạ xanh thủ
thuật thứ 15 lần cố định tiêu đề trang
in bây giờ các bạn sẽ sang cái ship là
doanh thu các tỉnh nhá Bây giờ các bạn
ấn càng được bê đi các bạn sẽ thấy này ở
đây mình sẽ chọn là diện factsheet nhé
Thì tất cả là có 29 Trang đúng không Thì
cái trang 1 để các bạn có thể dễ dàng
các bạn thấy cái phần tiêu đề đấy ạ Bây
giờ mình sẽ vào cái trang hay cảm thấy
cho các bạn sẽ không thấy cái tiêu đề
đấy cho nên khi quá in ra thì
Em biết là cái cột này là còn gì bố là
các bạn sẽ không hiểu được đấy ví dụ như
câu số liệu này mình chả biết nó là cái
gì cả đúng không Thì làm sao để mình sẽ
rẽ các cái trang còn lại nó cũng có cái
tiêu đề ở trên đấy nó cũng biết là gì ạ
Đây là doanh thu này lại đây là khu vực
ở đây là vùng đây là tỉnh lại nhá thì
làm sao để mình lặp lại cái tiêu đề đấy
Bây giờ mình vẫn biết đi chạy thì để làm
việc đấy các bạn làm như sau nhá các bạn
chỉ cần và với bếp leo này các bạn chọn
rồi pin thay Thôi đợi sau đó bạn sẽ
thích vào cái hiện các bạn sẽ thích và
cái vùng dâu stupid stop này Đấy nếu như
mà có bạn muốn kết tiêu đề này các bạn
sẽ chọn cái rễ cây hành các bạn sẽ thích
vào cái ô bất kỳ của cây hàng thứ Tư này
nhá Đấy thì nó sẽ lựa chọn cả hàng thứ
tư gọi đấy cho từ 4 đến bốn này còn nếu
như các bạn muốn lập cả cái phần trên
này nữa thì bạn sẽ Bôi đen hết Đấy tức
là địa từ hàng 1 đến tháng 4 đã đang sẽ
bấm điện bằng Ok Bây giờ các bạn ấn
compare Gọi cho thấy làm kgp đấy Bây giờ
còn xanh đấy bạn ơi cho cái tiêu
khi bé từ cái tiêu đề là đến khách hàng
thứ tư là luôn luôn cố định đấy Bạn thấy
hồng rất là hay luôn rồi anh lại nha
Sang thủ thuật thứ 16 là tạo vùng in ấn
nhá thì giả sử bây giờ mình muốn tạo với
vùng in ấn là mười cái thủ thuật này như
thế này thôi không ạ hoặc là mình Bôi
đen cả cái tiêu đề mình chỉ in cái vùng
này thôi đấy thì bạn sẽ Model cái vùng
này và các bạn sẽ vào cái gì ạ Các bạn
vào cái thẻ Tết Nay em này các bạn chọn
vnedo và các bạn chọn xét Vario thì như
vậy nó chỉ in cái vùng mà mình sẽ Thôi
bé qua tấn thật trước PV vậy thôi đấy
thì nó in chị ạ chỉ đến cái 10 thủ thuật
này thôi rất là hay luôn Ok mình sẽ bóng
bay nặn nhé bây giờ để bỏ cái đấy nha
thì các bạn lại vào cái thẻ Vina các bạn
sẽ chọn cái pin LED Bạn sẽ chọn cái clip
đi sang thủ thuật thứ 17 là chèn cái nhá
Trang bây giờ các bạn sẽ sang các thiết
kế và kinh doanh nhá đ
dự án căn trên p Gọi sẽ thế này đấy ở
đây nó sẽ có hai trang bây giờ mình sẽ
muốn là gì cái phần đồ thị này nó sẽ làm
một trang riêng và cái phần dữ liệu nó
sẽ làm ở một trang riêng đúng không có
hại trong bầu bí kiếp này thì nó cũng
tương tự như cái thủ thuật ở trước thôi
thì có thể làm các bạn thì nó cũng chính
là cái pajak ở trước thôi nhưng mà các
bạn có thể tích bàng ngay cái hàng thứ
17 là và các bạn chọn cái patria Các bạn
chọn cái Ajax và các bạn chọn Insert
object là thức làm gì mình sẽ tạo nhá
Trang từ cái hàng thứ 17 là bây giờ các
bạn thích kế mà bây giờ gọi sẽ ấn cái
bên B gọi thấy này Đấy nó sẽ nằm ở hai
cái sheet khác nhau để cái phần đồ thị
nó sẽ nằm ở ngôi khác đúng không Bây giờ
các bạn xem bấm biết kiếp nhé mình sẽ
vào lại cái gì Các bạn sẽ vào cái các
bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ view này còn chọn
Black preview này à
Ở đây còn thấy hiệu ba chàng ví dụ cái
trang này gọn kéo xuống dưới thì như vậy
là cái đồ thị nó chỉ là mở một trang hơn
đúng không để các bạn ngon mời các bạn
Caribê đi lúc này nó chỉ ở hai trang
thôi kết 1 của hai là đấy thích kết xanh
đấy thủ thuật thứ 18 là bỏ cái vùng in
ấn thì chính là cái vừa xong bỏ im một
nhấn là diễn lúc đấy mình in ấn nhá Lúc
em mình chọn nó cùng in là dễ các bạn
Bôi đen này các bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ vết
Lem Này các bạn chọn pin LG các bạn xét
clear đúng không Bây giờ để bỏ cái vùng
in gọi thích vào đây bạn chọn diện clear
Green areas Thôi để Ok như vậy là mình
đã xong cái bài in ấn ở đây nhá mình sẽ
mở cái câu hỏi của phần bài tập về nhà
sẽ các bạn này các bạn xem ở cái câu hỏi
lên thì cái câu hỏi của mình là dị ở đây
là cái vùng dữ liệu của mình nhá các bạn
ấn can trên p à các bạn sẽ thấy nó sẽ
làm ở bốn Trang đúng không Bây giờ mình
muốn co lại là một trang thôi mà có bạn
mà yêu cầu là
anh không chọn cái calang ở đây là híton
xin đâu nhé mà yêu cầu là gì mình sẽ
không chọn đấy khít Sit on one piece nhé
lại mình không chọn cái đấy đi đấy là
cái câu hỏi của bài tập về nhà cho các
bạn nhé Ok như vậy là mình đã kết thúc
bài học ngày hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn các
bạn đã theo dõi các bạn nhớ đăng ký Kênh
để cập nhật video mới nhất của gà cũng
như chia sẻ để giúp mọi người cùng học
Excel nhé Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại ở